you have one of your hoodies do you
seriously have to ask hey youtubers it's
Charlie this week on arrow we finally
got to see Roy's Rocky training montage
- the tube socks we also got a nice
shout out for the Suicide Squad just
like last week I'm doing an arrow Q&A
tomorrow night be sure to subscribe to
get it
any big questions you want me to answer
just include in the comments we got a
lot to get through I'm trying to get
this video up before I hit a hundred
thousand subscribers and I'm pretty
close so let's do top five moments and
then I'll do my review number five
sideways skin claw Wolverine reference
this is the DC Universe but did anyone
else get a Wolverine vibe when that man
started digging bronze Tigers claws out
of his skin
we saw the claws come out but what about
the hinge that he fastens them to I
think that was what was hidden in his
legs without those hinges though those
blades are just sharp knives so he had
to have those hidden somewhere inside of
him number four all the Malcolm Merlyn
shoutouts for an episode that did not
feature John Barrowman the characters
mentioned Merlyn a lot I kept expecting
him to show up in the end teaser he's
got to come back sometimes
so I'm guessing that's gonna be next
week's League of Assassins episode bonus
high fives for the Tommy shoutout I've
seen a lot of you ask if he's ever
coming back but the only evidence I have
for that is this behind the scenes photo
that Stephen Amell posted to his
Facebook page number three drunk Laurel
I'm really just talking about the last
scene but I knew her going off the deep
end was gonna be what Oliver used to
bring back Black Canary so whenever he
made that phone call in the bar I kind
of knew he was talking to her
she's back in the next episode as we saw
in the teaser and Nyssa al Ghul is
coming to get her it sounds like they
had some sort of relationship what I'm
really wondering though is is who's the
Oliver and who's the Felicity in that
situation number two it's really more of
a squad we finally got our first
official Suicide Squad shout out the
writers have been talking about it since
Comic Con but it took half a season to
get there I'm predicting that we'll see
them on a mission for Argus before the
season finale this year and they'll
definitely be part of season 3 I don't
think we're gonna see Harley Quinn
anytime soon though so don't expect the
same roster from the comic books and my
number one moment
no surprise here do you have one of your
hoodies do you even have to ask best
moment of the episode a lot of you guys
have asked me which version of Roy I
think he's going to be on the show it
doesn't look like they're training him
to use arrows so I'm gonna say you know
not the red arrow but I do think that
they're going to be making a lot of red
jokes that hoodie will probably be his
unofficial you know
form for the rest of the season but I am
predicting that during the season finale
you know in the aftermath of whatever
the final battle is Oliver will give him
a real red leather uniform just like his
Green Arrow uniform honorable mentioned
totally goes to Felicity's bronze tiger
joke it wasn't the best moment of the
show but it was definitely the funniest
bronze tiger what a stupid name Tigers
don't even bronze so a lot of stuff
happened let me know your favorite was
in the comments below was it Roy rocky
training montage was it the island
scenes or was it the Suicide Squad shout
out overall I gave the episode a solid a
- if Oliver hadn't revealed himself and
brought Roy into Team arrow I probably
would have just given it a B+ I give
extra points for aggressive pacing in
case you missed it there was a giant
tease for Slade son Joe that's Jericho
from the Teen Titan comics he's got his
own set of superpowers so I'm really
interested to see if Jericho comes on
the show next year I'm definitely not
expecting him to make an appearance at
this season that would actually be a
really cool storyline for Slade next
year it would be like a Tommy and
Malcolm merlyn's situation I'm really
glad that drunk Laurel Ark is going to
resolve itself quickly I don't know if
the subsequent Redemption arc will mean
her becoming the true Black Canary or if
it will just mean her cleaning herself
up right now I'm really digging caity
lotz as the canary so I hope she doesn't
leave the show any time soon hint hint
arrow writers if you are watching this
video the only other good reference I
caught was the Milo Armitage the arms
dealer in the comic books he was the
grandfather of the connor hawke Green
Arrow let me know if you saw any of the
references that I didn't list in the
video the big ones were Roy red arrow
Jericho and Suicide Squad though like I
said I'm posting that Q&A video tomorrow
night be sure to subscribe to get it
include any comments you want you know
about Jericho you know future story
lines or even stuff in season 3 so as
I'm posting this video I am passing
100,000 subscribers so I want to say an
early thank you so much you guys are so
awesome I'm actually doing a special
thank-you video that I'll be posting
tomorrow so look out for that right now
click here for my Q&A and click here for
last week's arrow episode thank you so
much for watching you guys are awesome
high fives I'll see you tomorrow
you